the tragedy of spaceflight is that you
can't get pizza I'm Mike Massimino and
this is how food is different in space
[Music]
my flights were to the Hubble Space
Telescope our job was to repair upgrade
refurbish that telescope through a
series of spacewalks an hour altitude
that Hubble it's about a hundred miles
higher than the altitude of the space
station so we get to see less detail but
we get to see more of the curve of our
planet so you see this gigantic
ball taking up your field of view and
it's it's magnificent
so to eat on earth you have to first get
your food and I don't live on a farm so
I have to go to the grocery store in
space it's different the food we have in
space is prepared by our cooks our food
technologists we have a whole food lab
at the Johnson Space Center the way you
pick out your food is you go to lunch at
the food lab and they give you things to
try and you would rate them on a scale
of 1 to 9 and so like a brownie score
that a nine if you like brownies
asparagus which is great that might be a
little less than a nine but you still
gonna have to eat your vegetables even
if you don't like them some of my
favorites I really did like the macaroni
and cheese I like lasagna tortellini
ravioli I like Italian food apparently
spaghetti and meatballs were good my
only one getting hungry with this she'd
never do this around lunchtime
I got the other type of meals we have or
meals ready to eat more or less that you
would find in camp food or the military
these are what's called the raid
they used to call them irradiated but I
think it scared people so then they
change it that thermo stabilized I don't
know what they did for the irradiated I
think the same thing they tried it to
scare us and you can warm them up eat
those I'm gonna cuddle my Beast
as you can see it doesn't look too bad
all the ingredients are already in there
the only thing you might add is a little
bit of spice to it maybe you add some
Tabasco or you want some ketchup salt
doesn't work because it'll float around
so it's liquid salt or liquid pepper
that is added to the mean friend of mine
he wanted to cater the whole flight and
that's like now I can't do that but they
allowed us to fly some biscotti from his
restaurant what they had to test it so a
sample was sent and they tested it and
now we get some of our specialty stuff
some things that we like
I like fluffernutter's and so I got sent
up some fluff so I could make my
fluffernutter with peanut butter if it
was available in the store so if it's
something you can buy off the shelf like
cookie or a cracker that stuff that's
already been checked out that's kind of
like good enough you can fly that stuff
in space there was pizza flown recently
on the space station I don't know what
it tasted like I'm very very skeptical
but I missed pizza in space on my first
space flight mission I ordered pizza
from space from a pizzeria in at near
the Kennedy Space Center I was able to
contact them through email and say this
is what we want
where's our landing time we would like
to deliver to the hotel we were gonna
stay at that's how much I miss pizza the
other thing you kind of miss is some big
to bite into cheeseburger or something
like that you know that you get a big
sandwich you can't really do that so
easily you get a burger and if you want
to put it in something you have to put
it in in a tortilla we don't have breads
that's the thing we're missing bread for
the amount of room it takes up it
doesn't give you a nutrition you might
want and it also provides crumbs and it
can go stale and stock the best tortilla
is nice and thin you can stack them
together you get a couple thousand of
them you know in one area and you wrap
things in them and they work really well
everything that stuff is disgusting
I think the reason that there's so much
of it in the museums around the world
that you can buy it in these little gift
shops is because astronauts will not eat
it
the way we package things on on earth
for liquids that can come in a carton or
they can come in a bottle you know you
have refrigeration so you're gonna fresh
meat vegetables frozen foods things can
be wrapped with clear app or box or
whatever it might be it can be a little
air in there without much penalty food
that goes into space needs to be compact
easy to prepare a nutritious and it
needs to taste good because no one wants
to eat crappy food in space what's on
the menu tonight strawberry shortcake
ten years strawberry shortcake
really for you Chris food is all
processed at the Johnson Space Center
for the NASA food items so they try to
make it really simple for us so all the
food when it's packaged for us it is
pretty much ready to go
these are rehydratable items so we can
actually see what's in there turkey
Tetrazzini so it also has velcro on the
back so you could stick it to the wall
or to your tray or to your leg or
whatever you want to stick it to the
consistency of these things is important
because we you don't want crumbs and you
don't want to be losing your food so all
of our food items have a little bit of
liquidy consistency to them if you were
to just like get a bunch of Cheerios on
a spoon without any milk and I mean
you're gonna be floating around you're
gonna be chasing them so that comes with
a little bit of dehydrated milk that
would be at it and then the Cheerios
will stay there's no gravity working on
any of this stuff and so the surface
tension in the liquid is almost like a
glue it is not glue but it's almost like
a glue then that surface tension those
molecules will stick to the spoon
macaroni and cheese spaghetti and meat
sauce ravioli even the shrimp cocktail
has a sauce to it so that that'll act as
the glue so you won't lose this stuff so
it all has that liquidy consistency if
it doesn't if pretty much have to get in
your mouth in one bite like a cookie you
know because if you bite into that you
create crumbs crumbs are an issue and
getting thing floating around getting
somebody's eye so you really want to
contain it so you don't cause issues
with the shuttle program at the
beginning of the Space Station program
we had individualized menus but you
could get what you like that started to
be a little bit too problematic now
they've gone through more like a
standard menu where these are the things
available over these six months in each
state figure out what you want to have
on the space station there is a
refrigerator they can use for a small
amount of fresh food and a little bit of
ice cream we didn't have any
refrigeration on the space shuttle
when we had fresh food and fresh food
means like orange or an apple something
like that you needed to eat that stuff
in the first couple days and you had to
promise your commander that you were
gonna heat it because if you did it then
went bad and rotten fruit is a problem
because we don't have a real good way to
dispose of things from the food science
part of this we have really smart
dieticians they look at what you like
plan the meal out so that you had you
know the right amount of protein and
calories if anything was the caloric
intake based on your size I'm a pretty
big person compared to most astronauts I
got a pretty full set of meals I guess
compared to the others I flew with they
plan you menu out and I tried to stick
to it you know mom's not always there to
make sure you're eating your vegetables
let's put it that way and you can get
carried away on the MMS if necessary
yeah I gained weight and spit I was
willing a few guys to to gain weight in
space I think me and a guy named Mark
Lee if you only they were amazed I think
what it was as I was in really good
shape when I when I went into space I
toward the end of the mission I was
eating a you know I think a little too
much macaroni and cheese quite frankly
apparently there's more food than you
could ever eat it might not be
everything you want to eat no you may
run out of the stuff you really like the
way we did it on the space shell says it
was kind of individualized meals
everyone had a color associated with
their position in the shuttle like the
commander was red the pilot was yellow
and my first flight my color was purple
and then I was a brat so just about all
your stuff your gear has these little
dots and colors on it so you know who's
who so your checklists and some of your
clothing and it has this dot on it and
all your food items they put this dot on
it so you knew who was it was but then
as you become an experienced astronaut
you realize that those dots are just
sticky dots so if you've run out of
shrimp cocktail and let's say your
commander has a bunch of them left and
you've got asparagus with your dot on it
and he's got shrimp cocktail with his on
it you can peel I'm not saying ever did
this but you can peel those dots off and
switch them and now the asparagus has
the red dot and shrimp cocktail has the
my purple dot on it and that's what was
sudden mind and I'm going to eat it
[Music]
breakfast is during our post sleep
period scrambled eggs or a sausage patty
or granola or a yogurt lunch is kind of
as you can get it and then dinner was
generally on the shuttle and on the
space station as well is more of a
community meal where you it's kind of a
nice thing to have the interesting thing
we learned from the Russian program
while we were going to the moon they
were working on orbiting laboratory
flights like Mir for example and they
learned a lot about keeping people in
space for a long time and the idea of a
community meal and having a table to
have a meal around in space for a sense
of community was important for morale
and for bonding and feeling normal sort
of like the way we here on earth we
followed their lead in there are tables
on the International Space Station that
usually have a crew meal or if we didn't
have that on the shuttle but we would
generally usually have like an evening
meal what everyone kind of float near
together that was a nice thing to do
[Music]
when we prepare a meal on earth we go to
the kitchen
typically we're combining ingredients
maybe a little water mixing things so
you need a lovin or microwave or the
ability to boil things that's the way of
course all of us are used to cooking on
earth in space it's different
[Music]
you might notice there's all sorts of
foods here it's like opening the
refrigerator you got all your different
stuff that you want to have drinks meats
eggs vegetables cereals cooking in space
your food is in what we call a storage
locker if you're gonna have breakfast
you might say well okay and want a bag
of coffee and you might say oh I want
some eggs today so I might have I like
the Mexican scrambled eggs that was
really good and so you get all you
little you'll get your breakfast
togetherness there's gonna be pouches of
stuff the rehydratable food at the top
of the package is a valve the valve has
got a piece of foil above it the valve
is the same for the food or for the
drink package and there's a needle
that's sticking out from the water
source of the galley the needle puncture
is a foil at the top of the valve and it
tells you how much to add like 5
milliliters so you choose hot or cold by
punching the right button and Red's now
good idea in space cuz that's more for
emergency so blue is cold and yellow is
that is the warm water and then the
water is delivered through the needle
into the packaging so I'll give you a
suggestion like this much more to ten
minutes and that means don't eat the
thing for ten minutes let it soak up the
water and if you want to warm it up a
little more because the hot water even
isn't really that hot you put it in the
food warmer in the oven for a little
while and that heats it tastebuds still
work in space but you tend to be a
little stuffy in space because your
bodily fluid is held in position by
gravity on earth in space it tends to
pull to the upper extremity including
your head
I like Tabasco and spicy things what I
even notice some of my crewmates they
wanted a little more spice on your food
and space because you're not smelling as
well and you're a little stuffy maybe
and so that helps clear you up so I
think Tabasco isn't it's very important
in space travel eating on earth we're
pretty much familiar with that using
silverware napkin your foods on a plate
and you can put wherever you want where
and we'll stay there so that's what it's
like on earth we've all done that well
in space it's different cutting things
is not as easy to do in space things are
floating around typically the food is
something that if it needs to be broken
up you can break it up with your spoon
the spoon is the most useful utensil to
have I'd never used a fork or a knife up
there to eat just the spoon everything
just came out with this bone you need a
scissor nearby so you can cut open the
bag carefully cut it open away from the
velcro because you want to keep your
velcro grab your long spoon because it's
a long container
each inside chocolate pudding cake
so what you can do instead of arranging
your food on a plate in you know the
separate pieces of food here and there
what you can do is arrange them with the
velcro because each one of the food
items packaging has velcro on it and
your tray has velcro to so you can do it
that way here's a cup of coffee for the
drinks go through that same hole you
insert now a straw stick my straw I mix
it up and it has a lock on it and the
reason it has a lock on it is that after
you finish taking a drink you'll lock
the straw if you do not lock your straw
there is the possibility of that liquid
getting out of the top of the straw now
I can come out of there and I was
hitting the eye with a drop of hot
coffee because one of my crewmates
didn't block their straw the way liquid
behaves in space it forms a bubble it'll
hit something against splatter but when
it's floating around it's more or less a
bubble one of my friends got up you can
play with water you got to be careful
but he got a pretty big bowl of water
going and he put a Swedish fish to the
side of every head like an aquarium
floating around but locking the straw is
a sign of a good astronaut chocolate
cake and coffee foods not so bad
so just like on earth when you're done
eating in space you gotta clean up the
packaging now that had food and it no
longer contains food so that stuff has
to be dealt with that is normally
considered to be wet trash separator wet
trash from our dry trash so what trash
is smelly clean off your utensils you
generally look them clean as best you
could you just to make sure you could
take like a handy wipe clean it off as
best you can and then you would throw
that handy wipe in the wet trash much
easier to clean up in space than on
earth
so put her like trash in these
waterproof bags on the space shuttle the
trash we would compact it as best we
could and then we would have to take it
home you couldn't throw that stuff out
into space so we would put that in our
trash area which was generally under the
floor on the space station that's
different
there's cargo ships that go up to the
space station that deliver cargo and
they get emptied out all the cargo comes
out and then some of those spaceships do
return to earth but others burn up in
reentry there one use spacecraft so all
your trash will go in though is kind of
like a dumpster and then that gets
sealed up undocks and will burn up in
the atmosphere so that's the way you
deal with trash on the space station we
more or less bring all of our food with
us from Earth and that's works pretty
well right now but for the future I
think it's gonna be required to somehow
be able to create food as you're on your
journey growing food is something that
we've experimented with on the space
station we have been able to grow
lettuce you can eat in space and this is
a think very important technology
development on the space station and is
going to be necessary if we're gonna be
traveling in space long distances
because you're not going to be able to
bring all the food you need for long
journeys into space so I think this is
pretty important work to be able to
figure out ways to create food on your
journeys that are going to be longer in
the future growing food in space there's
been a lot of research done even some of
my students at Columbia have done this
where are you trying to see what does a
plant need to grow in space you have
limited water so looking at ways to grow
food with limited water aeroponics
hydroponics is a study of doing those
things is also bigger facilities that
are experimenting in those techniques on
the ground they have applications not
only for space but also for the world
where there is a lack of clean water or
a lack of good soil being able to create
food in places around the world where
it's hard to do that
that's a nice spin-off of space
technology
food is really important in space travel
and a lot of people think that we're
eating out of tubes or even stuff that
isn't pleasant I think it was a case
maybe the earliest parts of the space
program but it's more than just
nutrition we have to remember that we're
still human and as you go on these
longer voyages away from home being able
to take a little bit of what you're used
to from home from Earth with you is
important and so that is the foods we
like to eat in the sharing of the meals
with friends those are really important
things it's not just the nutrition it's
also the psychological benefit that you
get food is important on earth and in
space astronaut ice cream I think is
more closely related to a building
material than it is to a food I think it
is something you might use to repair a
wall you know we said oh I want to go to
space so badly I'll need anything and
then you'd put that ice cream in front
of people anybody I'm gonna find another
occupation people are not going to eat
that stuff who are adults and go to
space